in the great before the average hot and
extremely athletic man could win MVP or
a Super Bowl but now there is only momes
this year will be different hey is this
the MVP race I think I'm going to make a
push woo Motor City looking motor PR
coach I don't think we quite fit in
Daddy's got a new system take that
haters no one's really hating on you
anymore the lack of haters are my new
haters run it back indeed it is time for
a running back I didn't say the ultimate
system
QB oh what a lovely
play careful trap Gams
ahead
uh-oh H we only let ourselves get
stopped by good teams oh no good teams
hurry up hurry
up okay Josh don't get distracted oh
gosh a
Defender you really got to stop these
turnovers that's right this year a
Defender has a chance oh damn bro I'm a
mirage what's that CJ St CJ St behold
coron St the bo b play with car time
time use my only weapon n shy you hang
up first okay time to lean on the
defense this is for last year you got to
be more specific I beat a lot of teams
last
year I will win MV I will
[Music]
not Ju Just get me to mid December I'm
trying my best oh classic mainstream
media making the post episode tag about
us and doubt how much the Giants
suck